[Musik]
kranke und herzlich willkommen im druck
der zentrum in hochfilzen mein name
worten aus der buchholzer in gruppen
kommen antrag der gruppe derzeit
befinden sie bei uns 60 tiere davon
sechs eseln unsere hauptaufgaben sind im
mittel und hochgebirge
trag zug und reits einsätze
durchzuführen
unser großer unterschied ist mehr
besitzen esel wie haflinger und dazu
gemäß den er in so und das ist jetzt
unser haflinger muss man daher in
großteils eindruck der zentrum davon
derzeit 56 stück schau wie folgt aus wir
haben die technischen daten bei die
druck tiere sondern es sind
leistungsparameter der haflinger ist ein
super gebirgs pferd stammt aus tirol
wurde damals gezüchtet für den truck
einsatz im hochgebirge die parameter für
unsere pferde jetzt im allgemeinen das
pferd namens lucia hofft netto zu last
auf dem pragsattel 100 bis 130 kilogramm
im zug jedoch zum beispiel beim
holzrücker oder wenn ihr lasten ziehe
hinten noch schaffen sie bis zu 300
kilogramm unsere pferde muss man immer
sehr individuell einschätzen es geht
darum man christ größer gebaut stärkere
gebaut schmächtiger gebaut dass wir mehr
sehen uns immer auf das traf das
jeweilige bestens entstehen können und
im gegensatz dazu stehe jetzt in hesel
vor
diese setzt unser esel namens chef
schaut wie folgt aus der erste ist
einfach kompakter gebaut schneller
gebaut das heißt es auch auf kleine
schmale wege für uns auch einsatzfähiger
der esel im gegensatz dazu dass er
kompakter ist oder natürlicher weniger
wo sie drohen kann seine netto zu los
beträgt circa zwischen 60 und 80
kilogramm und im zug circa 100 bis 150
kilogramm der erde ist sehr gutmütig
sehr schnell lernfähig und ist kein
fluch der usa die ausbildung wesentlich
verkürzt schaut wie folgt aus der esel
ist super fürs hochgebirge da auf bis zu
5000 meter ohne akklimatisierung quarks
co das makro schnelle böen änderungen
durchführen mit die esel immer wichtig
wenn man daran denkt an auslandseinsätze
so das war jetzt der erste und jetzt
machen wir nur einen rundgang durch
unsere stellungen im druckzentrum so
jetzt befinden wir uns aber in ihre
boxen von die pferde des horster wohnen
sie wir haben ihnen zehn quadratmeter
große boxen für die pferde das heißt
über der norm gehörte einer geht's gut
erinnern dort findet die fütterung stadt
die pferdehalterin durchgehende drängt
möglichkeit das ist wichtig für die
gesundheit der pferde zum verdauen
erinnern im stall horster militärische
ordnung auf jeder seite jeweils ist eine
andere frage der gruppe das heißt für
uns auf der rechten seite befindet sich
die zweite gruppe auf der linken seite
die dritte so ist sehr übersichtlich und
einfach verständlich für unsere rekruten
gott jetzt befinden wir uns in unseren
futtermittel lager der wert ist futter
individuell auf auch abgewogen für das
jeweilige fährt schaut wie folgt aus es
befinden sie 2 gw depot vom stall dienst
des in 24 stunden sieben tage die woche
immer doof für die pferde egal ob
wochenende oder feiertag die sind dafür
zuständig durch die fütterung
ordnungsgemäß erfolgt die haltung der
tiere beziehungsweise der zustand der
tiere kurs derzeit befinden wenn sie
jetzt in unserer wellness oase für die
pferde daher in das sehen wir jetzt groß
den asta raster ist ein als gediegener
bei uns der 21 jahre alt das ganze hat
dort aus die pins einfach wohlfühlen ist
so wie binz menschen am horn mal
irgendwo wir wären im rücken oder was
das kann man sehr gut dadurch beheben
verspannungen einfach ein bisschen
mildern und damit die pferde auf auch
einmal wieso wellness hongkong und sie
entspannen können bzw im winter aber
wenn sie durch los sein zum ausdrucken
der pferde und zum wärmen der pferde
jetzt befinden wir uns in einem gruppen
magazin das ist glaub mein gruppen
magazin von der dritten praktik gruppe a
wie folgt aus mehr um zwei verschiedene
modelle von tätern jedoch greifen mir
besonders immer aufs ältere modell
zurück weil es auch in der handhabung
und nutzung und fürst einfach besser ist
natürlich eine möglichkeit zum ziehen
zum ziehen von lasten hauptsächlich
sorge einmal ziehen wir lasten wie
baumstämme bzw machen einen
patiententransport in den abtransport
und dazu haben wir natürlich auch
hilfsmittel wenn er auch kurz zeigen
darf der hammer die holz rück gewannen
das ist einfach wahr indem du sind jungs
mit dem baumstumpf einstieg im gelände
das heißt er leichter dem pferd auf den
widerstand des zuges ist er ganz klasse
gerät kindern mal genauso im winter
verwenden dass man so ok das pferd zieht
und dahinter sitzt ordner drauf und
konnte das pferd auch von hinten führen
dann geht's weiter natürlich auch mehr
sand befähigt dazu und in der lage einen
rettungssatz durchzuführen dann befinden
sie im hintergrund die reiz hätte jeder
fragt er hat bei uns seinen eigenen
vater sein eigenes gerät dazu jeder gut
wenn er ein pferd zugeteilt bekommt geht
hereinholt sie vor seinem dir den sattel
beginnt das pferd zu satteln und dann
geht's schon raus ins gelände
jetzt befinden uns in unserer in der
reithalle natürlich in hochfilzen
optimal vor allem im winter damals sehr
hohen schneelagen kommt darin erinnern
befindet sie derzeit groth der
ausbildungszeit bei der ausbildung der
pferde doch jetzt einmal hauptsächlich
darum um das bereiten und dass sie das
ganze gewohnt werden mensch der
kooperation erinnern haben wir jetzt
derzeit einen gruppen komponenten vom
ausbildungszyklus eine praktikantin der
landwirtschaftlichen lehranstalt weiter
die macht er
pflichtpraktikum wo sie braucht für die
schule mittlerweile schon die 27 wo es
mal erinnern für ein praktikum
unterstützen und jetzt geht es dann
weiter raus der luzern und der chef
warten schon auf uns sind bereit für
satteln und verlassen
unternehmensgelände oder langsam
angelangt heraus wenn unsere zwei
attraktive einmal das pferd luzern und
der esel der chef die werden jetzt von
uns einmal die satte guten lage
durchgeputzt ordentlich damit es zu
keinen druck und scheuerstellen kommt
und dann noch beginnen wir mit dem
sattel an der seite von esa das iss
neuere modell leicht umgebaut haben wir
bei circa 30 kilogramm dies muss man
am fertigen wert ist und bei circa 47
bis 50 kilogramm der sattel selbst
donzel osten wo es mann verlassen auf
die traktieren wenn man schauen wir
haben zweimal die praxen doch das ist
das große gepäck von einen kämpfenden
soldaten und dann hoch wenn man weiter
am pferd am luzern machen wir dann das
über schwere maschinengewehr der
sommerdom bei 70 kilogramm zusätzlich
zum sattel und jetzt geht es los wir
bereiten unsere pferde vor
gott werde durch die butter
[Musik]
seit sommer in so günstig schießen im
druck hat und wen wird jetzt gehen wir
drauf ein obwohl es wirklich darauf
ankommt wo es mal achten müssen damit
die tiergesundheit bei uns an erster
stelle stehen bleibt
jetzt ist kann man ahnt bin natürlich
verantwortlich für meine rekruten bzw
grundwehrdiener wo sie doch und
natürlich auch für meine trug tiere
darauf müsse besonders acht nehmen dass
dieser teilung korrekt gemacht wann ist
ansonsten hui sofort ein neuer schäden
bzw steuerungen am pferd die achte
darauf dass sie die korrekten abstände
ein heute beim fordert zeigt dass die
freiheit für das pferd bzw für ein esel
gegeben ist dieser seinen hals bewegen
als nächstes dass der bauch kurz unten
drinnen dann nehmen wir das hand also
dass hunt mars eine handbreite gegeben
bis sie vorn was ein vorderfuß und steht
natürlich auf die korrekte zu ruhm es
muss schon schmack rikon zum sein so
dass das ganze dann wirklich erhebt wenn
man im gelände unterwegs sind über
gewisse steigungen dann als nächstes
kontrollieren dass die last und sich
wichtig ist dass die last wirklich
arbeit ist druck da meinen kleinen
hüpfer macht das ist wirklich korrekt
und bombe hätte obendrauf das heißt die
schau einfach los zieht es wirklich
irgendwo aushängen oder was ist super
stabil in ordnung dennoch erstmal druck
gehen wir haben ein kind zeugt das ist
bei uns wichtig dass die lasten nicht
nach vorne rutscht auf die schulter das
heißt der wodka freiheit mehr zu bewegen
hinten muss sie dann kontrollieren dass
das hinter zeug um zungen ist so dass
wir nichts verrutschen kann sehr gut
dann haben wir den er soll fertig bin
zufrieden mit seiner arbeit sofort
wieder aus sie gehen ins gelände wenn
das nächste und zum pferd können zum
luzern der haut des mbo da es wieder die
selbe spiel fordert zurück erhöht seine
freiheit ist alles gegeben es befindet
sie keine bauch falte keine
eingeklemmter die zur ehrung ist in
ordnung
findet man nur noch stellen
jawoll so
die waffen sind korrekt ein kind wichtig
ist immer die ober lasters dass pferde
beeinträchtigt wird sei es durch auf
schlagen auf die gruppe hinten
beziehungsweise vorne auf den hals dass
das pferd frei ist einen kopf bewegen
kann wieder dasselbe wie beim esel eine
handbreite bis zum schweif ansatz
und am hinter zug oder genauso die
bewegungsfreiheit
der kastenform usm gehe ebenso korrekt
ein
crysis verzurrt
und hebt ordnungsgemäße durch die truppe
dann metern super gerät und wieder
weiterarbeiten konnte nicht dass man mit
beschädigten waffen oder
transportmitteln und kämen so
jetzt geht es weiter wir stellen unser
marsch bereitschaft herr mertens genauso
und dann geht man raus ins gefährt
[Musik]
[Applaus]